for the European Union and its member  states it is essential to turn our  political support to this peace process  that we have had since the very  beginning of it into a concrete support  to the implementation of the peace  agreements so the trust fund will allow  the European Union and the member states  to accompany projects  first of all focusing on the rural areas  for the concrete peace dividends to  reach the people starting from women and  children and making sure that  reconciliation and peace brings positive  results for the everyday life of each  and every Colombian if the fondo Kondo  canal bubble metier comparative essay  the sale is a sueño in Nakano record  shows podemos comenzar a ally beneficios  concrete owes a la gente estamos en un  gran momento de nuestras relaciones  gente dan europea iike Lumbee venimos  record en un camino hace el progreso ya  Serapis europaea tiene confianza en este  camino la tenido us avenido pagando in  thousandth year